ils étaient nombreux ce mardi à
retrouver les terrasses des bars et
restaurants de la ville de sarrebruck
non loin de la frontière française
et pourtant cette liberté accordée par
la région de la sarre ne va pas de pair
avec la volonté d'angela merkel
d'instaurer des mesures plus
contraignantes
la chancelière reproche à certains
landers de ne pas être assez strictes
dans leurs mesures anti qu'ovide car la
situation sanitaire ne s'améliore pas
outre-rhin
ce mercredi le gouvernement allemand
s'est dit favorable un confinement cours
est totale à échelle nationale
le nombre de lits de soins intensifs
occupé parle de lui même et une augmente
très fortement et beaucoup trop vidéaste
a raconté à filtrer les médecins en
soins intensifs sont inquiets et lance
des élèves des appels un costume en
cours et uniformes sont justes
il serait également important d'avoir
érigé vais jeter car nous parlons de
mesures et d'actions communes
je serai donc ce que tu as en gala
merkel et les 16 régions allemandes
doivent se retrouver lundi pour négocier
d'éventuelles nouvelles mesures pour
endiguer au plus vite la pandémie les
régions tentent de prendre les devants
pour se fournir en vaccins à l'image de
la bavière qui a négocié l'achat de
doses de vaccins russe foot nick v day
le ministre de la santé est venu me voir
ces derniers jours et un contrat
préliminaire sera signé aujourd'hui avec
une entreprise concernant la livraison
de spoutnik
si le vaccin est approuvé en europe
l'état libre de bavière recevra des
doses de vaccination supplémentaires par
l'intermédiaire de cette société sous
2,5 millions de doses de vaccins qui
arriveront probablement en juillet pour
augmenter la capacité de vaccination de
la bavière faux personne
la bavière plus grand land allemand est
le premier état régional à faire part
d'une telle commande alors que la
campagne de vaccination patine dans le
pays en raison de l'organisation
logistique mais aussi du faible nombre
de doses disponibles à ce jour le pays
déplore plus de soixante dix sept mille
victimes du coc vide